[Musique]
il y a 4 ans j'étais chômeur en gros je
traînais j'avais pas de maison
aujourd'hui je suis marié avec enfant
et ça me va très bien
papa je sais pas comment tu as fait
j'avais un boulot un peu moins stressant
que le tien
ah ouais j'ai enfin décroché un boulot
je suis roi de l'Atlantique
un demi milliards de créatures de toutes
les espèces marines connues sont ici
chez elle
et je ne fais pas l'unanimité pour
autant
je vais tuer Aquaman et détruire tout ce
qu'il aime
je vais décimer sa famille
et réduire son royaume en centre
[Musique]
il faut arrêter Menta l'effondrement
total est proche
comment as-tu pu laisser faire ça ouais
bon en vrai je déteste ce boulot un vrai
roi je te défonce
jette des ponts
il a gagné en puissance
grâce au tri dans noir
sous le règne du roi Atlant il y avait 7
royaumes
ce trident était leur fléau
le trident déploie sa magie noire
il cherche à éteindre la lumière
je sais pas ce que l'avenir réserve mais
on peut pas léguer à nos enfants un
monde sans espoir
tu te débrouilles pas si mal que ça
si tu montres la voix laissez royaumes
de suivre
[Musique]